Wie vielen nackten Frauen in anzüglichen
Posen bist du in den vergangen Monaten begegnet
- auf Plakatwänden, in Werbeanzeigen oder
hier, im Internet?
Sexistische Werbung gibt es auch 2020 noch.
Trotz aller Kritik.
– Sexismus ist kein Humor und auch keine
Meinung, sondern Sexismus ist Diskriminierung.
Die Werbeindustrie wehrt sich seit Jahren
gegen jede Form der Regulierung - erfolgreich
und mit Unterstützung der Politik.
– Es sind eben Fragen des Geschmacks.
– Das ist eine Frage des Geschmacks, Herr
Lindner?
Gucken Sie doch mal hin!
– Nein!
Ich gucke da jetzt nicht hin.
In diesem Video geht es um eine ganz einfache
Frage: Warum - überhaupt - gibt es noch sexistische
Werbung?
Die Antwort aber ist komplizierter.
Anfang 2020 ereignet sich auf Instagram etwas
Ungewöhnliches.
Eine Art Premiere.
Und dieser Influencer steht im Mittelpunkt.
Ron Bielecki ist der erste deutsche Influencer,
der vom deutschen Werberat gerügt wird.
Für dieses Foto.
Er wirbt für ein Nahrungsergänzungsmittel
“Nice Schw*nz Bro”.
Die Kapseln sind angeblich ein “Libido Booster”.
Der deutsche Werberat soll über die ethischen
Grenzen der Werbung wachen - und rügt diese
Werbung als “herabwürdigend und sexistisch”.
Mehr als ein halbes Jahr später ist nichts
passiert.
Die Werbung ist noch immer online.
Und hier beginnt das eigentliche Problem.
– Es macht mich so wütend, dass Sexismus
in der Werbung noch nicht vorbei ist.
– Ich bin Maria Popov.
Ich bin Redaktionsleiterin und Moderatorin
von dem funk-Format “Auf Klo”.
“Auf Klo” ist ein feministisches Format,
das sich unter anderem mit Sexismus beschäftigt.
“Ok, Leute, die Welt ist in Aufruhr.
Wie hat Frau Sex, wenn kein Penis involviert
ist?
Boobs, Melonen, Igelschnäuzchen.
Titten.
Take 1.”
Maria Popov macht Journalismus auf Youtube
und Instagram.
Und möchte, dass Sexismus hier keine Rolle
mehr spielt.
Ein Post wie der von Ron Bielecki ist für
sie ein No Go.
– Was nicht okay ist an dieser Darstellung
von dieser Frau, von dem in Szene setzen des
Produktes auf dem Hintern von dieser Frau
ist, dass die Frau in der nicht-mächtigen
Position ist, der Typ in der mächtigen Position.
Das ist eine total typische Darstellung von
einem sexualisierten Frauenkörper.
Sexistische Werbung ist keine Geschmackssache,
sondern eine reale Bedrohung, findet Maria
Popov.
– Sexistische Werbung stellt die Gesellschaft
dar.
Und so Witze, die unter der Gürtellinie sind,
wenn die mal eben so schön auf der großen
Werbe-Wand vor deinem Büro groß abgebildet
sind, führen die dazu, dass Witze auch im
Privaten, die unter die Gürtellinie gehen,
verstärkt werden.
Aber eben auch, dass sexualisierte Gewalt
klein gehalten wird und still gemacht wird.
Sexistische Werbung wie die von Ron Bielecki
ärgert Maria Popov nicht nur - sie fordert
mehr gesellschaftliche Kontrolle.
– Besonders alarmierend finde ich nicht
nur den Zuspruch, den dieser wirklich bekannte
Influencer bekommt, sondern alarmierend ist,
dass der Werberat das nicht verbietet und
dass das immer noch online ist.
Instagram ist superschnell, Nippel zu zensieren
und damit ganze Accounts oder Fotos zu sperren,
während so ein Video im Internet bleibt und
damit auch eine ganze Generation davon beeinflusst
wird.
Eigentlich soll der deutsche Werberat dafür
sorgen, dass die Werbebranche ethische Standards
einhält.
Das Problem: Die Werbebranche kontrolliert
sich selbst.
Und echte Strafen gibt es nicht.
Wer gerügt wird, kann einfach weitermachen.
So wie Ron Bielecki.
Doch das Problem ist viel größer als ein
einzelnes sexistisches Bild auf Instagram.
Sexistische Werbung ist weit verbreitet.
Das zeigt eine Studie der Frauenrechtsorganisation
Pink Stinks.
Über zwei Jahre lang haben sie bundesweit
sexistische Werbung gesammelt.
Per App und mit User-Beteiligung.
– Wir waren völlig überrascht.
Wir haben 5.000 Zusendungen bekommen und davon
war wirklich die Mehrzahl sexistisch, allerdings
nicht wie man denkt, auf den großen Billboards
oder den großen Kampagnen, das heißt, dort,
wo viel Geld ausgegeben wird, dort ist immer
weniger Sexismus.
Aber leider kann man ja heute über Photoshop,
kann jeder und jede seine Werbung selber gestalten,
so dass wir gerade im Handwerk und im kleinen
Handel sehr viel sexistische Werbung haben.
Überall in Deutschland finden wir Werbung
mit Frauen in halbnackten, sexualisierten
Posen - so wie hier eine Werbung für eine
LKW-Waschanlage
Wir wollen von Inhaber Santo Zavattieri wissen,
was Frauen im Bikini mit Autoreinigung zu
tun haben.
– Ist auch eine schöne Blickfang, denke
ich mal.
Die stehen grad da und waschen ein Auto.
Also ich habe keine Bilder gesehen, die ein
Auto von Frauen mit Klamotten gewaschen wurde.
In der Regel standen die immer im Bikini.
Also gab es ja auch keine andere Möglichkeit.
Und deswegen haben wir auch das Bild ausgesucht.
Wir konfrontieren ihn mit der Kritik des Werberats:
Die Frauen würden auf die sexuellen Reize
reduziert und damit herabgewürdigt.
–Es sind ja nur zwei Frauen, die im Bikini
ein Auto waschen und das finden die Kunden
auch ganz schön.
Und die würden sich sogar freuen, wenn die
wirklich live hier beim Waschen dabei wären.
Der Werberat rügte die Reklame.
Und dann?
Passierte nichts.
– Erstmal hab ich darüber gelacht, weil
ich finde, da ist ja nichts Schlimmes dabei.
Und, ja,ich sollte das abstellen, hab ich
aber nicht gemacht.
Weil – wie gesagt - ich bin immer noch der
Meinung, dass es nicht sexistisch ist.
Santo Zavattieri ist kein Einzelfall.
Auch Ron Bielecki stört sich nicht an der
Rüge des deutschen Werberats.
Warum hat er den Post bis heute nicht gelöscht?
wollen wir wissen und kontaktieren Ron Bielecki
via Instagram.
Doch er antwortet nicht.
Auch das Unternehmen Rockanutrition will mit
der Werbung von Ron Bielecki nichts zu tun
haben.
Man sei nicht sein Managemeent.
Komisch.
Dabei wirbt Rockanutrition noch immer mit
Ron Bieleckis Gesicht.Und der CEO des Unternehmens
posiert mit Ron Bielecki auf Instagram.
Über sexistische Werbung wollen die beiden
aber nicht mit uns sprechen und erteilen uns
eine Interview-Absage.
Auf den gerügten Post sind die beiden aber
offenbar ziemlich stolz und platzieren ihn
in einem Goldrahmen.
Doch nicht nur Influencer* und Kleinunternehmer*innen
lassen sich von dem ethischen Kodex des Werberats
mitunter wenig beeindrucken.
Auch große Unternehmen nutzen provokative
Kampagnen gezielt um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen.
2016 sorgte die True Fruits Kampagne #Samensaft
für viele Beschwerden.
Der Werberat schrieb dem Unternehmen.
Und dessen Marketingchef?
machte sich über die Kritik öffentlich lustig.
– Sehr geehrte Samen, Damen und Herren.
Uns erreicht diese Woche bereits das dritte
Schreiben des deutschen Werberats.
(...) Diese Vorwürfe treffen uns schwer.
Ich bitte alle mal den Pimmel zu heben!
Die Hand zu heben, die sich dadurch wirklich
belästigt, diskriminiert fühlen.”
Am Ende gibt der Werberat dem Unternehmen
recht und sieht von einer Beanstandung ab.
Und True fruits?
Macht weiter mit noch krasseren Kampagnen.
2019 gibt es einen gewaltigen Shitstorm.
– Sommer, wann fährst du endlich dein Cumback?
Und Cumback ist so geschrieben mit dem englischen
Wort für Ejakulat.
Der Werberat erteilt True Fruits eine öffentliche
Rüge:
Über seine umstrittenen Kampagnen möchte
true fruits mit uns nicht sprechen.
Per Mail erklärt es, dass es den Werberat
“gut” finde, und die Rüge aus dem Jahr
2019 “anerkenne”.
Verantwortlich für die umstrittenen Kampagnen
ist Marketingchef Nicolas Lecloux.
– Ich werde lieber von einigen nicht gemocht
und von anderen gefeiert, als dass ich everybody’s
darling bin.
Denn everybody's darling ist everybody's Arschloch.
– Was mich ganz besonders schockiert, ist,
dass die Marketing-Abteilung von True Fruits
ganz genau weiß, was sie dort tun, dass sie
wissen, dass das Sexismus ist, und wissen,
dass sie damit Aufmerksamkeit generieren können
und das Unternehmen letztendlich davon profitiert.
Die meisten Unternehmen reagieren auf die
Beschwerden des Werberats.
Doch wenn es darauf ankommt, können Unternehmen
auch nach einer öffentlichen Rüge weitermachen
wie bisher.
Müsste hier der Staat eingreifen?
– Ich denke, wir brauchen ein Gesetz gegen
sexistische Werbung in Deutschland.
Ja!
Weil der Werberat doch nicht die Möglichkeiten
hat, die es bräuchte, um allen diskriminierenden
Werbung entsprechend entgegenzuwirken.
Wir fragen nach beim Werberat: Schärfere
Gesetze gegen Sexismus statt freiwilliger
Selbstkontrolle?
Der antwortet nur schriftlich.
Und weiter:
Doch in anderen Ländern gibt es bereits Gesetze
gegen sexistische Werbung.
In Norwegen schon seit 1978.
– Ein Gesetz gegen diskriminierende Werbung
in Deutschland würde zunächst einmal vor
allem Rechtssicherheit bringen.
Da wüssten alle, dass es jetzt verboten ist.
Und es wäre auch klar: Es gibt Sanktionen.
In Deutschland sollte es 2016 soweit sein
- der damalige Justizminister Heiko Maas wollte
mit einem Gesetz gegen sexistische Werbung
vorgehen.
Dagegen machte die Boulevardpresse und die
Werbeindustrie mobil - mit politischer Unterstützung
unter anderem von ihm: FDP-Chef Christian
Lindner.
Im Februar 2020 gibt Christian Lindner sich
überrascht.
– Eine Gesetzesinitiative von Herrn Maas
haben Sie lächerlich gemacht vor drei, vor
vier Jahren.
– Ehm, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was
genau Sie meinen?
– Sie haben Herrn Maas mit islamischen Religionsführern
verglichen.
– Ja, ach das meinen Sie.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich.
Also es sind eben Fragen des Geschmacks.
– Das ist ne Frage des Geschmacks, Herr
Lindner, gucken Sie doch mal hin.
– Nein, ich gucke da jetzt nicht hin.
– Das ist ne Geschmacksfrage oder ist das
ne Frage von Menschenwürde.
Ist das nicht Frauenverachtend, sollte sowas
nicht verboten werden?
– Ich äußere mich zu allem, wo ich in
der Sache genaue Ahnung auch von der Rechtslage
habe.
Hier, das ist ein Thema für unsere Rechtspolitiker.
Die Gesetzesinitiative scheiterte.
Zu groß war der Widerstand - auch aus der
Werbebranche.
Stattdessen gab das Bundesfamilienministerium
eine Studie in Auftrag.
Bei Pink Stinks.
Für 400.000 Euro.
Seit vergangenem Oktober liegen die Ergebnisse
vor.
Seit Monaten ohne jede Reaktion aus der Politik.
– Das sind 400.000 Euro, die uns gegeben
wurden für zwei Jahre, um diese Studie zu
machen.
Und jetzt interessiert sie niemanden.
Wir haben überhaupt keine Rückmeldung von
den Politiker*innen bekommen, die letztendlich
die Studie beauftragt haben.
Das ist eigentlich nicht fair, den Steuerzahler*Innen
gegenüber.
Sexismus in der Werbung, belegt durch ein
teures Monitoring - und die Frauenministerin
zeigt kein Interesse?
– Eine Gesetzesreform lehnen Sie ab.
Auch haben Sie bis heute nicht reagiert auf
das Monitoring, sagt uns Pinkstinks.
400.000 Euro hat die gekostet, warum reagieren
Sie nicht?
– Ich weiß nicht, von welchem Monitoring
Sie das jetzt gerade sprechen.“
– Sexistische Werbung.
Ein Monitoring, das 400.000 Euro gekostet
hat, von Ihrem Ministerium in Auftrag gegeben
worden.
– Das muss ich mir im Detail nochmal ansehen,
was es damit auf sich hat und wir können
da auch gerne nochmal im Detail darüber sprechen.
Aber ich würde gerne, bevor ich hier eine
Aussage zu mache, mir das auch nochmal im
Detail ansehen.
Dieses Versprechen gab Franziska Giffey Ende
Februar.
Doch bis heute hat sich das Ministerium nicht
mehr bei Pinkstinks gemeldet, um über 400.000
Euro teure Sexismus-Studie zu reden.
Stattdessen heißt es jetzt
in einer E-Mail, Zitat:
– Es sollte das Ziel der Politik und unserer
Gesellschaft sein, sexistische Werbung abzuschaffen
und gegen Sexismus vorzugehen.
Und nicht nur ist das wichtig, weil sexualisierte
Gewalt besonders für Frauen in unserer Gesellschaft
ein riesiges Problem darstellen, sondern auch
Männer würden davon profitieren, wenn sie
nicht immer dieser mächtigen, immer starken
Erwartungshaltungen gerecht werden müssten.
Wie sehr ärgert euch sexistische Werbung?